[Music]
we really have to understand more deeply
what the implications of creating an AI
are and what not that we haven't already
created a is but and I think the bigger
fear with artificial intelligence that a
lot of people possess can actually be
solved by the fundamental ethic behind
blockchain technology because when you
think about systems logic and systems
integrity if the minds operating the
system lack integrity then the system no
matter how it's logically constructed
will lack integrity and I think the big
fear with AI has to do with the
centralization of power because the
moment that we put something in a
god-like state and we say you have all
knowledge in the universe you have all
power you have access to every piece of
knowledge that is created around the
world from every human being at once and
if we store all of that knowledge in
something that is all-powerful yeah that
is totally scary the idea of any one
thing having ultimate power that's
always just that's a bad idea that's
always been a bad idea but if we can
take these concepts and change the way
that we think about their ability to own
power I think that will change the way
that we perceive what artificial
intelligence will be able to do for us
because there will be so many net
positives created by these emergent and
incredible technologies and yeah if we
have every basic job of someone doing
something that doesn't fulfill deeply
what is their ultimate human potential
because why are we on this earth right
we're not cogs in a machine we're human
beings we are real deep in pathetic we
are creative and every person on this
earth has an unlimited potential an
unlimited potential that for centuries
has been constrained by the way that
wheat they
about resource allocation whether that's
resource allocation in terms of money in
terms of knowledge and if we can create
a world of infinite resource I think
that is fundamentally when we will be
able to unleash in a different way the
infinite human potential that every
person on earth possesses and you know
we're not we're certainly not at that
point in our human evolution yet I wish
we were but I think that we're on the
verge of something meaningful and
something beautiful and something
incredible and with any system it's up
to us it is up to our hearts and it is
up to our minds and is up to our spirit
and the way that we carry ourself into
greatness whether that's as an
individual or as a civilization but
that's our choice and I think that if
every person comes together and moves in
the right direction we will see a
positive evolution and aggregation of
human potential
[Music]